good morning good morning all right
excellent I'm part of Jahan yin vice
president for research at Carnegie
Mellon University welcome to the second
day of the inaugural meeting of the
Global Learning Council first of all let
me say that we had a terrific day
yesterday phenomenal participation from
thought leaders from academia industry
government of course private foundations
extraordinary conversations and
thoughtful exchange of ideas and just a
passion and energy about a topic that is
so important to our future as we begin
the second day it is my great pleasure
to introduce this morning speaker deputy
secretary Jim Shelton Jim told me to
keep it really short I tried I really
tried pulse again jim was nominated by
President Obama and confirmed by the US
Senate to serve as deputy secretary at
the Department of Education in March of
2012 previously he served as head of the
office of innovation and improvement in
the Department of Education working
closely with secretary Duncan jim has
led many of the department's impactful
competitive programs many of them you're
familiar with during the past five years
including the investing Innovation Fund
Promise Neighborhoods and other programs
that are focused on teacher quality
school choice and learning technologies
I personally had the opportunity and a
pleasure of working interacting with Jim
during my tenure in DC during my service
in DC jim has been a forceful voice in
Washington for designing and advocating
policies that promote evidence-based
approaches to supporting young learners
and also for innovative learning
technologies that can truly help
students achieve learning game
Jim came to DC with tremendous amount of
experience also in the private sector I
won't go to that gym were very thrilled
to have you here with us today please
join me in extending warm welcome to
ginger good morning good morning
everybody so first thank you for that
introduction Farnham and thank you subra
for having frankly all of us here and
everyone who's been involved in pulling
together the Global Leadership Council a
global learning council excuse me so you
guys a funny thing happened so I was
here all day yesterday which is very
unusual but very gratifying listening to
the conversation I think that the
importance of the work that you all are
taking on and the potential of it is
people use the word transformative too
often but i think it is nothing short of
the potential to be transformative not
just domestically but globally it's that
important and we heard lots of
conversation and so here's the funny
thing to happen I I had a presentation I
was going to make and I scrapped it and
then I started putting together new
presentation and I realized about
midnight last night is about five times
too long because you know I heard all
this great stuff during today so some
time between then and now I like chopped
it all the way down there's a bunch of
stuff that's not going to be in here i
have a whole thing about the ecosystem
of change and how we actually unlock
human potential about the connection
between research and investment and
demand and adoption and assessment and
evaluation and how that fits together
how field scans fit together with basic
research and directed development
through things like DARPA and a
potential art but for education lots of
stuff about all that I have lots of
stuff about potential R&D agenda for us
around seven specific areas of domain
areas where we could actually organize
our work and drive forward I'm not going
to talk about most of that so if you
want to talk about we can do that during
a question to answer I want to actually
jump really quickly
to what we're trying to get done and how
we do it because I think to have this
group together and not walk away having
at least argued about some of the things
that need to happen when we walk out the
door that many of you will engage in
either through this vehicle or on your
own is a missed opportunity so with all
that preface let me let me just go ahead
and jump in I think that what we heard
yesterday was very clear call to action
around a fundamental challenge that we
have in a learning space which is that
we need to change the way we think about
working so that we not only get really
great new outcomes that we've never been
able to achieve before but we do it in a
large scale and get away from these
individual examples now being am
recovering the consultant to have a
two-by-two for this right and it is very
simple thing around impact versus scale
now here's an interesting thing and we
can argue about this point but I would
choose not to today that we do have lots
of things that have an individual cases
demonstrated that they are significantly
better than a status quo unfortunately
many of those things are very small and
they stay small and i will call tend to
call those things inventions and
inventions are very very important
because they changed the possibilities
but we need our innovations that will
actually change lives which means that
they actually have to make the migration
over to go into scale now we've talked
about why that doesn't seem to happen in
the education sector and you heard it
through the conversations yesterday
sometimes it is a result of failures in
knowledge right either we don't actually
know enough or people who are creating
solutions are looking for solutions
aren't aware of what we know or people
may even know but not know how to use
that knowledge and in the context in
which they find themselves all of those
failures of knowledge and research are
challenges that we can actually overcome
and in cases we have these things are
all examples of us trying to pursue our
traditional strategies of dissemination
to adjust those challenges in the
cognitive sciences and actually what we
know and are able to
find about what we need people to be
able to do and understand about the role
of mindset and other molecule factors
and learning like we know a lot about
that we still have gaps but largely what
we have feared out and failed to do
figured out that we have failed to do is
to have the people who most often use
this information or should be accessing
it on a regular basis to make decisions
and I'm not just talking about class
from practitioners classroom
practitioners behaviors are driven by
hmmm these people call publishers these
people call preparatory institutions etc
we also heard about barriers and design
and engineering that we create things in
that they are so difficult or so unaware
of the context that our educators and
practitioners find themselves in that
they don't choose to use them or they
try to use them but they can't implement
them with fidelity because they're
complex and difficult to use all these
things lead to further challenges in
adoption because if it's challenging and
hard to use who's going to recommend it
to their friend yet what we know is that
we have a lot of know-how as a country
and as a as a globe about how to kind of
do the kind of design and engineering
work that takes very complex things and
make them easy to use and seem simple to
the user the classic example is the
iphone imagine the amount of complexity
that now resides within an iphone and
yet it shows up in the box and how many
people actually look at that little
trifold they send with it before they
start playing with it what have you ever
try to do an education that was like
that now I'm not saying that education
can be productize and is that simple as
I said everything should be as simple as
a candy and no simpler but what I am
saying is that with the right tools and
resources we can make great instruction
much more accessible for many more
people and great learning opportunities
the same we can do much better than we
do today
third area adoption in use now there's a
whole side to this about the demand side
about in the US the fragmented demand
about the relationship and buying
process the convoluted distribution
system which means that three basic
companies a control eighty-five percent
of the discretionary spending in kate's
well like there's a lot to be said about
that but the truth of the matter is that
adoption and use people make decisions
to use things because it's very clear to
them that there is a benefit in the
value they think they are going to get a
value from it they think it's going to
produce a certain outcome for them they
can afford it and then obviously they
are aware we haven't done a great job of
solving for any one of those and you've
heard it through the conversations today
in the yesterday that in fact we have
not made apparent to people those things
that work better and made it easy for
them to understand that there actually
is a value to doing it that in fact it
makes sense given the infrastructure
that they have in the research that they
have available that it they actually
have a hike feasibility of being able to
implement it we've not done enough work
to make that the case for everyone to
make adoption and use of the things that
are the best easy and let's be clear
that especially in education set is
enough talk specifically about k12 easy
is a value proposition and that's not
disparaging that's just a fact of life i
have 150 students that i see in a day
i'm supposed to know what every one of
them knows and is able to do and what
they're interested in so i can meet them
with the perfect instruction and content
to do that i get what oh the smart board
i heard those are good a matter of fact
I entire district bought them for
everyone I'll just leave that there
so what do we need when you take all
that together what kind of
infrastructure do we need to create very
different kinds of solutions to bring
the knowledge to the four to close the
gap so now is that we have to do the
kind of design and engineering that
needs to happen and turn those into
products and solutions that actually can
go to market and go to scale now we can
talk more about the demand side but I
want to talk about the supply side
excuse the simplicity that is drawing
but what it represents is working from
the outside in testbed sites you know
many of you are deeply involved in
evaluation on a regular basis and the
cost of evaluation is tied up in what
data collection lots and lots of touches
to figure out how you actually
instrument the place and get the data
that you need and in fact arrange it so
that is perfectly designed so it meets
your design protocols for the experiment
so you have the proper amount of rigor
to your studies and we do this in lots
of places lots of times with lots of
agreements that are all complex and very
difficult to put together and because of
that we trickle out a few dozen every
year that actually meet our bar for
rigor now imagine if we had sites that
were pre wired and prieur instrumented
where we already had our rb's and
everything else that you guys in a way
better than I do to have in place so
that the apparatus just ran and you
dropped your experiments in to learn
that from my friend or sex burger
somewhere in here that's what they're
doing at Kaplan is it fair to say that
sorry it's too late okay thanks
why I why shouldn't we be doing that
everywhere or at least in enough places
to give us the perspective that we need
now that's when you think about the
traditional educational setting we've
also gotten virtual educational settings
which are predisposed to the only being
able to do this and one of the great
conversations that we had yesterday than
a demonstration sessions is that in fact
if you have the intentionality on the
front end about building applications
that are designed to get better over
time you can build in the infrastructure
for experimentation and gay data capture
on the front end that allows you to
reduce the cost of doing that kind of
work on the back end the data is there
but whether we actually captured in ways
that allow us to do this kind of work is
the question now let's push it one step
further suppose we create a generic
infrastructure to allow many many people
to build their applications on top of it
to do that kind of work on an ongoing
basis so that when you developed your
applications they were developed with
the ability to connect to an
infrastructure that allows you to get
that kind of feedback someone told me
they may not be in the room the day that
they had actually developed specifically
a layer to do that provide that kind of
work generically support generically to
lots and lots of different applications
either way we could dramatically change
the way the field is learning about
what's happening in terms of virtual
learning overnight and in this case
we're talking about not tens and
hundreds of millions of development work
probably talking about single-digit
millions of dollars work for development
work to figure out how to create an
infrastructure that looks like this but
then you have to tie that to people who
this room is exceptional in many ways
because in many ways you have people in
this room who are both great designers
and great researchers and who understand
the market place and how you get things
to market right most teams don't look
like that I wind up with an incredible
amount of education apps that have to do
with messaging all right great stuff
but if you don't understand how to do
great learning experiences then the
limitations of what you're able to
create are the simplistic but when you
have that deep understanding you can put
it together with people who know how to
do great design and create things that
are truly impactful so how do we create
those innovation clusters that bring
those people together to cloud them the
infrastructure that they need to really
low-cost ways create these solutions and
take them the market and figure out if
they work and taking the scale because
what we heard yesterday is that the old
methodology of kind of cycling through
do you think you've got a perfect
outcome is under utilizing our capacity
dramatically to actually improve as we
go along using the fact that we have
balances if not hundreds of thousands of
millions in some cases users where we
can do many experiments to improve at a
much more dramatic pace than we do today
so the question is can we build that
infrastructure now here's the challenge
this is an old chart but it hasn't
changed much so education is you know on
the far right the Department of
Education is on the far right what we
spend in research and development in
this country specifically on education
is a fraction of what we spend another
areas yet we know that this is at least
as complex as any of those and has at
least as much potential to unlock the
economy to stabilize countries to do all
the things that we think are most
important in the world now I'm not going
to wait for that to catch up I don't
think that's like would happen I want to
try and get it quintuple that would be
great haven't done it yet but we fail to
realize the opportunity to use other
people's money now think about how much
money has gone into the brain work and
how little of that has shown up
in direct application to the kinds of
solutions that we're trying to create or
in the research that folks are doing in
the learning space even on the campuses
directly adjacent to where is going on
think about the work that we heard
that's happening in the military that
they're doing for training of military
personnel or things that are happening
in the training space that are having
with training adults because there is a
very clear market return think about all
of those places that where there is a
very clear application with potential
will required adaptation to the things
that we care most about where other
people are paying for it and for an
increment we can bring it across and
think about how seldom those
conversations actually happen let alone
how little infrastructure there is to
bring them all together there's no
reason for that other than our failed
effort or lack of effort to cause it to
happen this campus alone could change
entirely the trajectory of the learning
pathways on research on development and
everything else with the work that is
already doing in many cases funded by
federal grants here same it pit same at
Stanford same an MIT same it I could
just go around the country and it would
be true everywhere so we have a
desperate need for resources and we have
a desperate need for its new solutions
in many cases the resources we need are
here but having almost six years in now
on the government side here's what i
will say that infrastructure i talked
about will not show up if you wait for
us to do it private funding is going to
have to mobilize to start building out
that infrastructure building out the
localized innovation clusters supporting
the creation of the network's making the
connections and building the research
and development agendas all of those
things have to happen so let me move
speed up just a little bit so I think
that there are five steps
new ecosystem you can tell I cut out a
bunch of stuff right so one is we have
to design and build again I come back to
this global network of learning research
and innovation clusters here's what i
mean by here's my i say that you're
obviously all here because because you
believe it but i think it's important
for a couple of reasons one I agree with
almost everything that lewis said
yesterday like hundred percent on his
tenants the only thing i would put back
on slightly slightly slightly is there
is like five trillion dollars in a few
million people involved in the
educational enterprise we should figure
out how to put them to use but we can
build these networks and when we do
build them globally if we find ways to
provide high-quality low-cost meaning
affordable in developing countries
educational opportunity if we can create
those kind of solutions and for those
environments given their constraints by
definition when it arrives here is
completely disruptive completely
disruptive now the relative to the next
best alternative may not be quite as
great when it shows up here but when you
combine costs with impact will be
looking at things that are dramatic in
terms of the influence they got to have
on the field and let me just run through
the others the shared research agenda so
i say the ones talk about this but
things like what we talked about around
how people are but most importantly
something we often skip over is how do
we better identify and describe what
people need to learn and be able to do
to be a skirt to be masters think about
that example of the IT thing that Frank
did you have on e talked about yesterday
that the military created people really
get caught up in the digital tutor part
of that the breakthrough is in how do
you figure out what's so important that
great series problem solvers around
network administration do that you even
know what to teach in 16 weeks to have
them be able to solve most problems
and if you can answer that question then
everything else falls from that how do
you validate that what kind of
experience does create that what is the
shortest and cheapest way for you to be
able to do that in what context can you
keep people motivated enough to keep
going through that how does that change
based on the delivery methodology but
those first questions are still
fundamental we need an initiative very
specifically focused on we get really
focused on the substance of the work
which is great but as we've heard time
and time again here we have completely
different opportunities in terms of the
methodologies we can use and the tools
we have available we've heard about the
folks that are using machine learning to
actually do mine big data to actually
really understand what the patterns are
and learning trajectories in ways that
we never have been able to do before we
know very little about how to maximize
the use of that capability we need to be
able to do that imagine being able to
pull together the different disparate
data sets that we have not only about
couldn't stuff about learning but other
things might know about students so we
can put that together to figure out how
context matters both individual and
environmental to change those
trajectories think about the privacy and
ethics issues we have to address as we
do that so there's a body of work
specifically about how we do this work
going forward that I believe this
learning council ought to be focused on
fourth thing the for-profit sector so
why does the military and health why do
military and health have the rd budgets
that they have I will posit one part of
the answer there are people who believe
that if the government invests in rd in
that sector it will benefit them so the
biggest lobbyists for funding to the
biotech in genetic research that feeds
the biotech industry are not the
universities doing the work it is the
industry itself
the people who are going to use the
research that's going to change practice
are going to be the large publishers and
others be they for-profit or nonprofit
that are using those tools and resources
to change outcomes if those people do
not engage especially in this
environment in this country to influence
whether or not they're spending on
research and development and the nature
of those partnerships it is going to be
a long long uphill battle and they scale
as we saw I would do a lingo really
quickly sometimes at no cost to the
student and lastly advocacy policies
that reward efficacy and evidence the as
a person who's been in government for
six years now the thing I would love to
be able to do is just pay people for an
outcome like you get somebody a job I
got you boom you get paid can't work
that way for a whole variety of reasons
but the next best thing is to pay based
on the probability of an outcome that's
what evidence is our systems don't work
that way they don't reward it people
don't expect it and people are confused
about what they get that pretends to be
evidence so creating the context for
both FC and evidence to be the thing
that drives buying decisions is the most
important thing that we can do to change
the incentives in the marketplace and I
will call it that for both ideas and
solutions whether you are nonprofit or
for-profit it does not matter if you can
get people to do what you have use what
you are selling use your idea adopt your
practice without evidence because
evidence is hard to come by sales not so
much
the last thing and running around with
my town sorry that's why I should be
short this stuff is really important I
do believe there's one other thing that
gets in our way so I know the evidence
guy but I want to assert something the
same way that you know most of the time
you put your hand and fire it's hot I
want to assert something else you very
seldom me two three or four year old
that you don't meet think is singularly
impressive like they are just amazing
like every time you meet one day that
kid is going to rule the world and we
know it doesn't quite work out that way
and I think part of that is because
there's lots of reasons but part of it
is because we actually have a belief
system that we reinforce with our
systems and I'm not going to argue the
point about IQ here with the bell curve
I'm just arguing the point about
performance and our systems
reinforcement performance curve that
looks like that instead of assuming the
performs curve on the far right now
imagine if the general orientation of
our systems in our culture assume that
assume that there may be a distribution
of intelligence but frankly everybody's
got what they need and the question is
how are we going to get them to that
point now here's the really crazy part
remember the Louise talk about Bloom's
taxonomy yesterday I mean bit sorry that
blooms taxonomy the others bloom the
sick to see my problem so we already
know that we can take folks who are in
the middle of the pack and get them to
the 98th percentile we know we can do
that we know exactly how to do that but
we allow ourselves not to do that
because we can't afford it
think about that
so there's lots of reasons to do this
but to have this knowledge and not find
a way to solve this problem I have a
deep fear that there is a special place
in hell for letting it stand so thanks a
lot
right thank you very much Jim we have
time for a couple of questions let me
invite you to that either side there are
microphones that you can pose a question
for Jim all right as you're thinking
about your question let me pose a
question between you know you you
mention the inaccurate inadequate lack
of investments in the area of education
especially from the private sector what
are some of the ways and we know that
there is a seismic shift is taking place
in learning and education what are some
of the ways that the government can help
to mitigate or lower risks when it comes
to investments from the private sector
sure and so there's lots of ways for us
to lower risk out to stick with
especially cuz been talking a lot about
learning technology how it applies in
particular in this base so one of the
ways that you see it is through things
like the connected initiative that the
president launched to make sure every
school in the country actually has the
infrastructure so you get connectivity
to the schools you work with the private
sector to be able to provide devices at
a much lower cost for many systems
making the transformation in making the
initial acquisition is just a matter of
critical mass of ideas and opportunities
for resources but being able to
aggregate that in a way that lets them
get in the game like if you don't have
the infrastructure everything else gets
much harder the other thing is that
we've seen this happen in other sectors
is we can actually create demand before
the kind of solutions that we want to
see and invest in the research and
development and/or cause of research and
development to be invested and so here's
what I mean by that what we know is that
we've seen advanced market commitments
and other things work in other sectors
for vaccines and take your pick we could
easily be doing that the education space
I think it's even much easier outside
the United States than it is you know we
have 15,000 school districts clin going
on but we have yet to figure out how to
overcome our our barriers to really do
that well when we created League of
innovative schools that was the original
intention listed aggregates about three
and a half million students worth of
demand if you will but figuring out how
you allow them to aggregate that demand
to call for a new kind of solution set
is very tricky we should be
to do that and frankly using the
military and others I think we can do
that especially if we pay attention to
these adjacencies there are things that
we can where we have real control take
advantage of it and then use it for the
things that where we have less control
thank you Jim we have a couple of
questions sir let's start from this I
please introduce yourself and also your
affiliation I'm bro saxberg with Kaplan
Jim what you spoke about fits so well
with what the Global Learning Council is
about and so that's terrific what one of
the interesting issues that keeps coming
up but doesn't have a you know a set of
solutions against it i'm curious how you
would think about it is the demand side
not not just from you know government
bodies but even from you know students
from families from people going in from
employers even what is any thoughts on
what we should all be doing yeah to get
the sense that you can do better I mean
if we can actually convince America we
need whiter whites is there some way we
can convince ourselves that we need
better learning solutions any thoughts
on that yeah I have a few thoughts on it
it is obviously one of the hardest
things that that we have the reconcile
ourselves with because human nature is
such that people eliminate the distance
that they have about what's happening
with their especially their children
when it comes to learning right parents
are deeply satisfied with the schools in
their community they know the rest of
the system is screwed up it's not that
they are illogical they kind of know
just you don't want to believe that and
you don't want to believe it so bad that
you forget so we have to get better and
better at actually showing people that
these outcomes that these differences
are there we have to be able to show
them that these differences are there
but there are exceptions to the rule
with people who live in very similar
context to what they live in and that
those differences in outcomes produce a
very different pathway of opportunity
now that's all very conceptual but think
about it this way for I'll stick with
the example that we talked about
there's a two groups of recruits that
came in that went into those training
programs there's one groups of training
trainees who went into this education
Dominus program who came out 16 weeks
later and all of a sudden are on ships
next two guys who went through the other
program that was twice as long they are
on the same team and the the commander
is actually using their informal
authority to make them the head of the
team meanwhile the other person is
sitting there trying to figure out how
to get basic work done that's really
really clear we can extrapolate those
kinds of examples for people both
through data and through examples to
help them start to see more and more why
these differences in outcomes actually
make a difference in lives um we suck at
it we really really are bad at it and I
would say that's regardless of sector we
don't have a way because there's only
one talked about yesterday to really
differentiate the it's to spell out what
the outcomes are we're shooting for and
so people ride on a lot of other stuff
reputation word of mouth history well
data is about to change all of that like
LinkedIn pretty close on their app and
they released the version of it that is
going to be able to show you pathways
that people have taken from the 300
million users that they've got tied back
to the institutions they went from and
basically it's going to become pretty
apparent like if you need it to spend
the thirty thousand dollars or you could
have got the same thing for ten thousand
dollars from somewhere else so little
things like that are going to help but
we have to tell the story in a different
way sorry let's take two quick questions
over there and wrap up Emma brunskill
from Carnegie Mellon University can you
talk a little bit more about the
innovation clusters and in particular
could you reflect about how large do
they need to be so that then those would
be convincing enough demos to then scale
up this innovation to nationwide er
worldwide sure so I go ahead and you ask
a second question Ken go ahead I just
say no no I got it can I just wanna get
his questions we can answer in Boca
think the point you made about in the
other
sectors industry is driven more
government funding was really intriguing
and I guess I'm wondering as we think
about how military and medical have done
that is are they doing that because the
funding goes directly to those industry
research centers or is it indirect in
the sense that they see that the
university research helps them in the
longer run okay so that one's easier it
is it is indirect but more direct right
so the partnerships that have started to
form what's more deeply in both health
and in the defense between the industry
and the research infrastructure means
that they know that there is going to be
real value coming out even for the
things that they see coming from the
basic research trend but on the
innovation clusters this is this is why
I think I do tend to think about
critical mass but for because of my
persons I think a lot about districts in
the k-12 space but I also think about
and so the large ones are easy to think
about because you usually have a
research institution etc also think
about clusters of you can even think
about service areas in rural context so
you're able to aggregate many rural
districts so that you can get enough and
get enough critical mass there to both
be able to do a reasonable size study
and also to understand what some of the
differences are the key though is that
you can actually have large and small
clusters if you have the network because
then you have a shared data shared
infrastructure that lowers the cost for
everyone at participating so that you
can get smaller players into the game
now the entire cluster in my mind
includes the researchers the educators
and practitioners providers meeting
entrepreneurs and investors as well as
designers and engineers to help get the
stuff right and I think having enough
critical mass to support all of that in
a cluster or cluster Network cluster is
pretty important you know one thing that
we haven't talked about is you know we
why some of the great individual
findings that we have in research don't
make it to market place they're not real
products
if you if you saw because you're really
interested in as a research or a
discrete problem that's really
interesting to you n potentially
scientifically important but it's not
broad enough to actually meet a need
that's cross-cutting that changes the
nature of work and makes life easier and
better and more likely to produce an
outcome for a person who has to
implement it like it's not going
anywhere so we need to be able to pull
these things together into things that
actually aggregate two solutions good
deal okay once again please joining
thanking me Jim for a terrific
reservation we're gonna have we're gonna
have a slight change to the program to
accommodate everyone's travel schedule
we're going to have a shorter rapid and
let me invite president suresh to the
podium to say a few words so i wanted to
take just a couple of minutes to give
you some of the upshots of the meeting
the business meeting of the global
learning council today i was going to do
it later at the closing session because
the business meeting was just held this
morning I wanted to give things up up
this update to you while things were
still fresh on my mind before I get
sucked into a lot of other things that
have been waiting for me so there is a
first reason the second reason is that
some of the key participants because of
flight schedules and travel schedules
have to leave so I wanted to do that
while many of my GLC colleagues are
still in the room one of the goals of
this organization or this virtual
organization is to ask the question how
can we move the needle in this important
problem that Jim was alluding to and we
intentionally started with a starting
cohort of about thirteen members
representing very different sectors even
though it's called Global Learning
Council initially as I mentioned
yesterday morning
it's primarily us centric because of the
center of gravity of this activity as
has evolved to be in the u.s. initially
of course the beneficiaries of all the
things that we talking about and
potentially the customers of all of this
and potentially the people who are going
to move the needle in all of this and
not necessarily in the US there are many
in the u.s. there are also many people
outside of the US so we've been very
much mindful of this equally importantly
we wanted to make sure that we have
tangible actionable products with clear
goals and clear deadlines because it's
very easy to talk at the hundred
thousand feet here for days at end and
months at n and not get anything done so
with that objective in mind yesterday
and today members of the GLC had a
number of discussions and remarkably
given the diversity of their backgrounds
and the diversity of their perspectives
and the diversity of their agendas in
their institutions that they serve they
converged on two topics that they feel
would be significant initial starting
points for GLC to try to address with a
clear deadline which I'll come to in a
minute to problem statements there are
there are clear needs now and how do we
address that need through GLC problem
statement number one current
practitioners do not have a trusted and
understandable information source to
help them promote evidence-based
technology influenced or enhanced
learning in higher education so for that
problem statement our action item number
one is the following the GLC will
develop and provide understandable
criteria and evidence for what works in
terms of best practices in the design of
learning environments best practices in
continuous improvement and best
practices in adoption of these tools
that's action item number one
problem statement number two many
organizations gather large amounts of
learning data and are willing to share
these data for education and research
however currently there is a lack of
widely accepted principles and criteria
for sharing data therefore action item
24 GLC the GLC will create a framework
with principles and criteria and I
emphasize principles and criteria for
the sharing of learning data so GLC is
not an organization that has any
authority to tell anybody what to do or
what not to do it's purely an
organization of experts coming together
to provide input and insight from very
different perspectives so we feel that
these two action items we will take up
we will create documents both in
electronic and physical form this will
be vetted through a large body and many
stakeholders so our timeline would be
that between now and about April or so
with help from lot of the GLC members
with input with other entities with
federal agencies with forums with think
tanks etc we will create these documents
of course the two action items that i
mentioned have a lot of sub components
to them and they were some of the
members of the GLC who come from
different sectors have offered to help
not only to seek input but to
disseminate this information for broader
context it could be funding agencies it
could be entities such as EDX or
Coursera it could be entities such as
Association of American Universities or
association of public and land-grant
universities our current plan is to
develop a draft document and Hunter
Rawlings president of AAU has offered to
bring it up to the AAU presidents
meeting in April this is the 62 top
research universities
in the US and Peter McPherson has
offered to circulated at the appropriate
time to if not the full membership of
APL you the relevant remembered that the
group of a PLU between those two they
represent about two-thirds of the top
100 universities in the world so if we
can seek input if ultimately the goal
would be that some of these best
practices so these two action items will
also involve best practices evidence
examples etc that will feed into the
criteria so that's the goal in parallel
for some of these questions there are
task force that our members were willing
to work we very much hope that
government agencies who do funding
through their own infrastructure
entities such as Department of Education
and NSF in particular with a lot of
experience or of course NSF I know in
much greater detail then I do the inner
workings of Department of Education will
play a critical role there are a lot of
experts in this room so that's sort of
our initial aspiration and several
people pointed out if we achieve half of
what we aspire to achieve in this time
frame and in this manner it is likely to
have some significant impact on a global
scale well the last point I would like
to make is about the next meeting we
have intentionally because we wanted to
have specific action items we have not
chosen the venue for the next meeting
there are three at least three entities
that I've offered to host it there are
many others who have expressed
preliminary interest one within the
United States one in Europe and one in
Asia and there is there is no lack of
interest there I can tell you the next
meeting will not be at Carnegie Mellon
University by design it has to be
somewhere else and it may very well be
outside the US but wherever it is I
think the GLC will make a decision
within the next 4 to 4 4 to 8 weeks or
so on the next location and
and we hope that will be in a position
to talk about these two action items in
a concrete way no later than the time of
the next Annual Meeting approximately a
year from now give or take a few months
so that's all I want to say thank you
very much we're going to get back on
track I promise so let's take a short
break ten-minute break and invite you
back for our final panel thank you